Hi, I'm Mattie Wasiak.
And I'm a junior studying
computer science.
And my project is--
I've been looking at a data
set called Data Warehouse
Connect to try to use
it to optimize oxygen
delivery to the preterm infant.
And so the motivation
behind this
is it's important to keep
preterm infants within a set
oxygen range because if
their oxygen dips too low
it's called hypoxemia,
which causes mortality,
and if it's too high, it's
called hyperoxemia and causes
morbidity.
And so we have this data set
called Data Warehouse Connect.
And it provides quasi-real-time
data, including alarms,
trans physiological
wave forms, SvO2 data,
access for all the patients
in the NICU at Beth Israel
Deaconess Medical Center.
And so we sampled this data
set to get patients that
are preterm, which is
less than 37 weeks,
and also in the hospital
for more than 24 hours.
And so this led to 367 patients.
And so we looked at
the oxygen saturation
for these 367 patients to
determine that the coverage
that we had.
And so we found on average we
have 96 percent data coverage
for these patients.
And so this means from
the time of admission
to the time of
discharge, we have
second by second
oxygen saturation
information for 96 percent
of the patient's day.
And so this leads to about 8,000
patient days of oxygen data
showing that this is
a very rich data set.
And so when we dive
a little bit more
deeper into the oxygen
saturation of the patients,
we grouped the patients
by gestational age
and by birth weight to see
how these two factors affected
the percent time that they spent
outside of their target oxygen
saturation range.
And so we found patterns
that you would expect to see.
So we found that the most
premature patients and also
the patients with the
lowest birth weight
were the most likely to leave
their target oxygen saturation
range.
Thank you.